once you realize that nobody gives a
[ __ ] it's liberating because what that
really gets you two is two cents if
nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] when you die
why the [ __ ] you weren't about their
opinions while you're alive
you got your perspective be happy don't
you want to be happy oh my guy how are
you when's the album dropping and look
at same time for everybody cause it's my
book you might use it cool yeah good
Inga's that's cool let's tweet it I'm
quitting [ __ ] you [ __ ] the world I'm not
from this life nice
who's gonna care your mother and your
sister cool bounce like what like nobody
gives a [ __ ] yeah
life goes on like nothing like [ __ ]
dying like [ __ ] and we're still like
moving on like like the greatest like
Michael Jackson dies and then like this
24 hours we give love and like maybe get
a week if you're an all-time legend
palta nobody's talking about John McCain
today nobody's talking about baby Bowie
today nobody's talking about Prince
today Prince in today's world you get 48
hours on social media if you're an
all-time and then everybody's back to
their [ __ ] life it sucks
no it's actually beautiful cuz I love I
love Prince too many little red Corvette
is my jam for life gosh it's amazing
because then all of a sudden once you
realize that nobody gives a [ __ ] it's
liberating
cuz what that really gets you to is to
sense if nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] when
you die yeah why the [ __ ] you weren't
about their opinions while you're alive
you'll get the Monday to Monday thing
for him because I want to use that video
give him love oh don't tell gosh by the
legend himself you're here New York City
[ __ ] fourth-quarter
faster this man
[Music]
so can we push that you know I'm pushing
it 10 minutes oh hello to see you
brother are you real pleasure
yeah real pleasure what's up man yeah
good to see you yeah hello sir how are
you sir
real pleasure I can't believe well
you're here my pleasure my pleasure the
biggest question I have is you know when
building an audience there's so much
that goes into it number one you have to
have something to say yeah and I think
the best thing to say is your truth yeah
you know some people like you clearly
have a truth I have a jar we all of us
in this room have truths I think the
biggest mistake people make is they
aspire to be something that isn't their
truth thus they deviate from their
message because they want to grow or
they want to speak publicly or write
books or play football like whatever it
may be
uh so the biggest thing I can tell you
is don't forget for ten years I was
doing fine but nowhere close to what's
happened to me in the last 15 months
right
so like first it's a journey you're a
young man
you're young as I think because I'm I'm
pretty sure your uncle's a young man and
the way I think about light which is
life is long yeah and so I think first
and foremost my man it the secret
ingredient the core to the foundation is
patience I really mean that I think I
think in a world where everything's
being documented unlike the world your
uncle Tony and even I to a degree in the
early part of my career the things we
did are lost in history lost in history
yeah when you're building an audience
online everything you do is documented
forever yeah so patience has become
unbelievably important number two the
question becomes what are you really up
to intent matters incredibly one of the
reasons I think I have a big advantage
is I don't want to monetize my audience
yeah you know I build other businesses
that allow me when I put out content to
not use it to get people to pay me
$6,000 to be their life coach or
$100,000 to be in my Gold Club my
ability to create economics outside of
the people that follow my content has
allowed me to put out my content for
free but you have to recognize more than
anything that if you want to inspire
people , you would like them to give you
money in any shape or form yeah you have
to reconcile that and make that
authentic the biggest vulnerability that
everybody has in a world right now is
everybody wants to be a motivational Mis
and a motivational that they say that
they want to just inspire people and
then in the backend they want to make
money off those people let me say this
on the record forever I don't get to
judge that I don't think that's even
necessarily wrong yeah but it's wrong to
say you care about something when it's
just a facade to something else when you
start asking for money from an audience
you should have zero expectations that
they give you any one of the reasons
I've been able to be so successful
is when I have a sneaker I want to sell
them I'm not bashful to say hey guys I
have a new sneaker but when I tell you
that I have zero expectations of anybody
buying I have zero expectations yeah
would it be nice sure you know my thing
is you're gonna buy shoes anyway I take
it but when I put out content if you
notice and you're smart guy a lot of
people put out content but they're not
giving you their best stuff they're
using it so that you pay them I'm
putting out my best stuff every day yeah
free your stuff myself the most of it
you can for them the most and then not
that the money will come but no question
that will build you more leverage just
do that no no I think asking asking
here's my question what do you want the
money for like what are you asking for
asking is fine expecting or or
manipulating what you're doing for free
as a gateway for them to then pay
because people manipulate and then you
get to the punchline and like well now
you got to pay five thousand dollars and
like [ __ ] now what you see where I'm
going very important my question to you
is a different one what are you asking
money for I think posting do you want to
buy a t-shirt of this is it ask that's
more than that's fantastic I love that I
think if you actually put out as your
best content as much as you can you'll
build a bigger audience which will mean
inevitably you'll sell more t-shirts you
know what I mean yes yeah I mean look
look once in a blue moon
life is good happens and you build a ten
million dollar 100 million dollar
apparel business but what happens 99.9%
of time is you build a nice little
schwag business that maybe can make you
happy with what you're getting out of it
your Instagram your you said to put up
the truth thing what's your truth and
I'm good and I've won the 60-second Club
and they said what's your truth and I
was in a wheelchair I'm okay with it I
throw one thing at you cuz I got a run
in a minute the thing that I get out of
you in this time that we're spending I'm
a very big believer in people aren't
complaining way too much and then once
you start that path it's big trouble you
get into entitlement and dwelling you
know the fact that you're so on the
offense yeah like the permission you
have to be like I'm not complaining what
the [ __ ] are you doing yeah is a very
big whitespace something you should
think about yeah
period yeah it's a big it's it's the
biggest breakthrough for society right
now
and you have so much you can do with
that okay you should make a you should
marinate on this and try to make a piece
of content of like if I'm not
complaining the [ __ ] are you doing
that's basically the potential the 50
million viewed video because of your
situation if you take anything out of
this limited time we had together like
you have more what I've taken from a
little I watch from afar and then the
time we spent here don't overthink it
just put out put out ship route okay
you're on the right side of this 100% if
that's how you want to justify it cool
no no I'm telling you I like that that's
not a negative sure see if it sticks
learn something from it one piece of
content that doesn't get a lot of likes
and it helps one person is good content
[ __ ] likes like there's a million
whatever you say next the answers gonna
be yes
that I love them I love the [ __ ] the
journalist thing yeah
and brother I'll tell you this and
you'll appreciate this had I not been
under the mental strategy of just put
out the content I would have never
gotten to those pillars yeah I know what
my content gets the most likes but
that's not interesting to me what's
interesting up that I'll take pictures
with puppies yeah like what's
interesting to me is making an impact
that's collateral to the DNA that I was
gifted yeah like that's interesting and
and that doesn't mean pandering to
social media likes that means the reason
it feels authentic can make as much
content is I have things I want to say
and if you can benefit others awesome
yeah and like I love listen there's real
things I love the attention and the
admiration this feels good to me right
now like that should listen it is what
it is I feel very comfortable in saying
that I also loved way more getting the
emails from people and saying like
you've changed the course of my life
like I don't know how much I don't know
I don't know a good wired human being
that doesn't think that's the greatest
yeah so every time you think well it's
only authentic for me to have one piece
of content but then you're looking at
what what you're eating or what you're
watching or what you're talking about
like make a video right now about your
thoughts on why the Cowboys lost that
first game you may say that's not a
piece of content that's gonna get me
into I think that's exactly the piece of
content that's gonna get you there
do you see where I'm going yeah it's
making a more 360 picture of your life
so just do I put out you know especially
when the Jets like after that money like
[Music]
I was that you know that's myself no I
don't drink it I I'm so drunk I don't
yeah I don't do anything but focus on
the game yeah thanks I don't want to
talk to any of them and you're sitting
there like a tree like I'll be there
baby I'll be there but I can't I can't
talk I can't because I got a card
I need to run to this brother I
apologize 100% isn't here what's up my
friend I get it you know why that only
feeds my thesis of putting out content
more more more MORE that is the answer
[Music]